[Musique]
en direct du centre national des arts à
ottawa
voici le débat sur les enjeux
francophone avec mathieu nadon
bonsoir très content d'être avec vous
dans un magnifique endroit on est à
quelques pas du parlement ce soir
que vous habitiez vancouver rigide à
sudbury gatineau ou encore moncton
l'accès à des services en français une
question tellement important dans notre
quotidien une question souvent
malheureusement éclipsé durant une
campagne électorale alors on a décidé ce
soir de braquer les projecteurs durant
une heure sur vos préoccupations a faim
on l'espère de vous aider à faire un
choix éclairé le 20 septembre nous avons
lancé une invitation aux cinq partis
représentés à la chambre des communes
qui ont désigné chacun un ou une porte
parole je voulais présenter
immédiatement avec nous ce soir alain
reyes du parti conservateur don soir
bonsoir monsieur rené villemure du bloc
québécois bonsoir bonsoir mélanie joly
du parti libéral pour tendre à luc
jolicoeur du parti vert dont soir
bonsoir et françois choquette du nouveau
parti démocratique bonsoir bonsoir sénat
dont merci d'être avec nous nos équipes
un peu partout au canada ont participé
au choix des thèmes et des questions qui
seront posées au cours des prochaines
minutes les candidats vont débattre de
quatre grands enjeux les voici on va
parler ce soir deux langues officielles
éducation économie et finalement culture
francophone jeu barcelone que la
position des candidats sur le plateau et
lors des interventions et est déterminé
par un tirage au sort je vous demande
tous et toutes d'être précis précise
dans vos réponses gardant en tête que
les électeurs veulent savoir ce que vous
leur proposez j'évite vos chefs la
semaine dernière qui ont été calmes et
disciplinés lors des débats alors on
s'attend à la même chose de votre part
pour briser la glace on commence avec
une question que j'ai pour chacune
d'entre vous vous aurez 45 secondes pour
y répondre allons-y mélanie joly d'abord
la modernisation de la loi sur les
langues officielles c'est la priorité
pour les organismes francophones peu
partout en milieu minoritaire vous avez
tout pouvoir durant six ans vous avez
attendu à la dernière minute juste avant
le déclenchement des élections pour
déposer votre réforme qui n'a pas été
adopté qu'est ce que vous dites aux
francophones qui doute de votre bonne
foi mais en fait quand j'ai été nommé
ministre des langues officielles
maintenant dans les coffres étaient
vides ottawa et en plus ça faisait dix
ans que les communautés linguistiques
appelez les conservateurs il ya personne
qui réponde au téléphone la francophonie
bref ce n'était pas important alors ce
qu'on a fait elle est libérale et moi on
a investi une somme record dans les
communautés linguistiques un milliard de
dollars au cours des six dernières
années et maintenant on a déposé un
projet de loi projet de loi ambitieux la
première fois en 30 ans qui fait en
sorte pour la première fois de
reconnaître que non seulement le
français est une langue minoritaire au
pays mais on doit faire plus pour
protéger le français pour arriver à une
égalité réelle en nos deux langues
officielles alors on a été là avec vous
on est là avec vous présentement et on
va l'être également dans le futur merci
beaucoup madame joly françois choquette
maintenant question pour vous dans la
plateforme du npd il est très peu
question de la francophonie de belles
intentions mais pas beaucoup de détails
quelles actions concrètement vous allez
prendre pour vous assurer de protéger
les droits des francophones et qu'ils
puissent être servis dans leur langue
peu importe à quel ordre au pays on peut
le dire le npd a quand même reconnu avec
ses champions deux langues officielles
des langues officielles on peut penser à
yvon godin par exemple qui s'est battu
pour le français partout au pays qui est
un fier défenseur des acadiens également
il faut de dire que lorsque j'étais à la
chambre des communes je me suis battu
également pour la défense de
l'université de l'ontario français pour
la défense des francophones partout au
pays pour la petite enfance en français
en 2015 on avait déjà un programme pour
la petite enfance en français les
libéraux malheureusement ont tardé à
mettre en place enfin commencent à
mettre quelque chose en place et c'est
important que dans la petite enfance en
français nous ayons des clauses
linguistique pour s'assurer que nos
communautés soient bien desservi merci
beaucoup monsieur chaque est rené
villemure maintenant du bloc québécois
lors des débats des chefs la semaine
dernière votre chef yves françois
blanchet s'est félicité d'être souvent
la seule voix des francophones hors
québec au parlement or monsieur blanchet
on a vu cette semaine a dû annuler sa
visite au nouveau brunswick clairement
votre parti n'est pas le bienvenu
partout expliquez-nous quels gestes vous
allez poser pour un délit francophones
du canada alors que votre objectif
premier c'est de défendre les québécois
l'objectif premier demeure de défendre
les québécois nous croyons que le québec
est le mieux placé pour défendre
sa position de francophonie de français
comme langue officielle maintenant
l'incident d'hier pour moi ça relève de
l'anecdote monsieur blanchet tête en
gaspésie j'ai payé une visite de
courtoisie à son voisin de caraquet moi
même je travaille beaucoup à kao nouveau
brunswick e-plus manque jamais
l'occasion d'aller faire un tour mais je
pense pas qu'ils avaient de mauvaises
intentions maintenant je crois que ça a
été monté en épingle et on a vu ce matin
le rédacteur en chef de l'acadie
nouvelle démentie ou du moins de
désamorcer ce débat là donc on aimerait
bien pouvoir aider les francophones hors
québec mon impose rien comme tel on va
tenter de leur donne un pouvoir de
négociation partager les connaissances
merci beaucoup allez reyes maintenant du
parti conservateur l'alliance de la
fonction publique du canada qui est le
plus gros syndicat de fonctionnaires
fédéraux pays demande à ses membres de
ne pas voter pour votre parti lundi
prochain le syndicat créé des
compressions si vous êtes élu
particulièrement dans les services en
français on sait que vous engagez à
rétablir l'équilibré budgétaire d'ici
dix ans puis vous garantir aux
francophones ce soir que vous n'allez
pas couper dans leurs services et que
vous allez les aider si jamais il ya des
provinces qui veulent sabrer dans la
francophonie oui tout à fait je peux
l'assurer à toutes les personnes qui
nous écoutent ça fait six ans que le
gouvernement libéral est en poste on a
vu toutes les erreurs que se sont
produites avec ce gouvernement là on a
vu comment le français n'a pas été
respecté j'ai moi même reçu des
téléphones de fonctionnaires de la
fonction publique qui m'ont contacté
pour dick ne se sentait pour respecter
lorsqu'il voulait travailler dans la
langue de leur choix en français on
s'est engagé à déposer un projet de loi
de modernisation des deux langues
officielles dans les 100 premiers jours
et d'éviter les erreurs de superman
libéral que précisant pour me déposer un
projet de loi 7 jours de la fin de la
session avant de sombrer en élections
c'est de ce n'est sûrement pas le genre
de choses qu'on va faire nous de notre
côté du parti conservateur merci
messieurs reyes soit on termine ce
premier tour de table avec luc joly car
le sujet les cas relève québécoise du
parti vert que vous dirigez vient de
présenter sa propre plateforme
électorale vous voulez en trop de
financer des programmes francophones à
l'université au canada également
reconnaître le droit des québécois de
faire du français la seule langue
officielle à la province il rit tout ça
par contre se retrouvent dans les
engagements nationaux du parti vert
comment vous pouvez nous expliquer ça
d'abord pour ce qui est du financement
des universités francophones hors québec
c'est dans la plate forme nationale du
parti
ensuite pour ce qui de tout le débat sur
la motion du bloc sur la loi 96 le parti
vert avec le député paul magnan voté en
faveur de cette motion rogge nous notre
propos c'est que faut pas faire un
élections sur le dos de cette motion le
lot faut passer à autre chose sur le
garder les vraies priorités les vrais
enjeux et ce qui nous préoccupe beaucoup
c'est la question de l'urgence
climatique et c'est sûr que les
questions francophones nous plus que
pousser au plus haut point notre chef le
dit le français pour elle c'est quelque
chose de très important c'est d'ailleurs
de ces questions francophone qu'on va
parler du rat durant le reste du débat
également merci beaucoup à vous 5
allons-y maintenant avec notre premier
thème
[Musique]
on va parler des langues officielles
notamment de la modernisation de la loi
fédérale une priorité pour chacun de vos
différents partis on veut savoir comment
vous allez y arriver la question nous
vient de la chef d'antenne du
téléjournal colombie britannique julie
karpaty la loi sur les langues
officielles est entrée en vigueur en
1969 et mises à jour il y a plus de 30
ans tous les partis s'entendent pour
dire qu'il est grand temps de la
dépoussiérer les communautés
francophones demandent une loi plus
robuste afin qu'un réel bilinguisme
émergent des institutions fédérales un
enjeu d'autant plus important ici en
colombie britannique puisqu'il s'agit de
la seule province sans politique ni loi
sur les services en français
que comptez vous apporter à la loi sur
les langues officielles pour permettre
aux générations futures d'avoir accès à
un espace francophone
alors question claire au nord d'entendre
vos réponses c'est maintenant la place
aux débats ouverts les cinq candidats
peuvent intervenir la parole d'abord à
monsieur chaque est bien merci beaucoup
tout d'abord ce que gagnent important de
dire c'est que l' approche libérale
telle approche conservatrice les deux
lions des trous dans leurs plans pour la
modernisation de la loi sur les langues
officielles du côté des libérales du
libé du parti libéral du a pas de
coordination de la loi sur les langues
officielles y a pas d'agent centrale qui
va être donnée au conseil du trésor ça
c'est un manque très grave pour la
modernisation de la loi sur les langues
officielles du côté des conservateurs la
nomination des juges bilingues à la cour
suprême c'est pas leur priorité c'est
pas dans leur intérêt donc ça prend un
parti qui va amener ramener toutes les
bonnes coulées bonne demande pardon des
communautés de langue officielle en
situation minoritaire médecin pour de
vrai dans la modernisation de l'offre
sur les langues officielles et c'est ce
que nous allons faire mais d'ailleurs
j'aimerais présenter la position
libérale parce que premièrement il y est
évident que la loi soit langue
officielle doit avoir plus de mordant et
pour ça il faut qu'on augmente les
obligations des ministères pour
respecter le bilinguisme et en même
temps on va donner plus de pouvoir à
notre commissaire aux langues
officielles on veut également que les
juges à la cour suprême soient bilingues
contrairement à ce que les conservateurs
proposent ou si on est d'accord avec le
fait qu'il doit avoir une agence
centrale au conseil du trésor
contrairement ce que mon collègue bien
le dire mais au final on reconnaît qu'
il doit y avoir un droit d'être servis
en français en droit de travailler
français est également ne pas être
discriminé bien entendu dans les
entreprises fédérales au québec et dans
des régions en forte présence
francophone dernier point j'aimerais
juste rajouter que l'on veut re déposé
le projet de loi sur les langues
officielles dans les cent premiers jours
à vtt remercie de me donner la parole ça
fait six ans que le gouvernement libéral
est en poids se fait six ans que madame
joly est là pour faire à voir si ce
projet lors toutes les comités les
consultations ont été faits les comités
parlementaires au sénat de la chambre
des communautés des ondes fait le
travail ont fait leurs recommandations
le commissaire langue et cela peut être
les recommandations les ministres déposé
son projet ses jours avant la fin de la
session avant que le premier ministre
déclenché des élections s'ils avaient
vraiment voulu mettre en place ce projet
de loi elle l'aurait fait bien avant et
pourquoi les gens sont aux abois
reprendre ce qu'on propose c'est clair
et c'est ce que les communautés
francophones nous demande partout
premièrement s'assurer que ce soit le
conseil du trésor qui s'occupe de
l'application de la loi de un deuxième
homme est en place un tribunal
administratif pour utiliser pleins et
s'assurer que les services francophones
soient donnés par tous donc deux
priorités que l'on doit mettre en place
rapidement vous donner plus de mordant
que le commissaire aux langues
officielles et plus de mordant qui
peuvent faire des ordonnances puisse
donner des amendes pécuniaires et c'est
la seule façon d'y arriver il faut que
le français devienne notre fierté on a
deux langues officielles et c'est pas de
gamins libéral qu'on voyait le chemin
suivi au pays on comprendre par contre
c'est qu'à chaque fois que les
conservateurs sont élus les droits je
vous ai laissé parler sa chaque fois que
les conservateurs sont élus à chaque
fois les droits des francophones recul
au peuple
haïtien le plan des concerts novateur on
a seulement suivi le plus de pouvoir
pour le commissaire aux langues
officielles vous êtes d'accord avec ça
d'accord mais cependant le problème est
que la loi proposée renforce le
bilinguisme institutionnel et non pas le
français il la loi ne reconnaît pas la
symétrie entre les langues au canada et
au québec à savoir que le lin les
minoritaires au québec est quand même
une situation différente du francophone
des minoritaires dans les autres
territoires donc le bilinguisme
institutionnel pour nous ça ne fait pas
c'est un recul la loi contribue à la
sueur complétion d'institutionnels en
finançant de manière disproportionnée
des institutions anglophones au québec
et ça c'est le canada qui se bâtit sur
la faiblesse du québec mais ce génie
quand je vous entends tu sur la question
de la modernisation de la loi vous
proposez quoi on lui tout à fait
d'accord avec la modernisation de la loi
puis on veut même aller plus loin il
faut qu'ils aient des services en
français pas juste au niveau du
gouvernement fédéral mais aussi dans les
entreprises de compétence fédérale et
c'est prévu en partie dans la loi mais
je pense qu'on peut aller encore ont pu
faire encore mieux notamment le
transport entre les provinces
les services bancaires les services de
télécommunications les francophones
doivent avoir de véritables services en
français au canada et c'est comme ça
qu'on va attirer des immigrants
francophones au canada et qu'on va
rétablir le déséquilibre linguistique
mai dernier point si si on avait voulu
adopter cette loi là il y aurait pas
fallu déclencher des élections il y
avait aucune raison de déclencher ces
élections là et l'on se retrouve en
campagne électorale ça s'échauffe décidé
on aura l'occasion d'ailleurs de
reparler d'immigration c'est un petit
peu plus tard maintenant face à face
toujours dans la question du bilinguisme
autres rené villemure et mélanie joly
tous tous les deux vous êtes d'accord
avec le bilinguisme obligatoire des
juges de la cour suprême du canada d'un
autre côté madame je lis votre
gouvernement des mines gouverneur
général qui ne parle pas français
expliquez-nous cette décision le qui
crée vraiment une onde de choc dans la
francophonie mais écoutez je pense que
on peut faire confiance à madame cinq
mines ce qui est une grande québécoise
une grande canadienne et sincèrement
c'est une femme de parole première femme
autochtone nommé gouverneur général elle
s'est engagée à parler le français
apprendre le français et je suis
convaincu qu'on peut lui faire confiance
madame semaine comme diplomate avait
l'obligation d'apprendre le français
dans le passé et elle a eu de nombreuses
années pour le faire ce qu'elle n'a pas
fait elle vaut peut-être la prendre
maintenant d'accord mais comme diplomate
elle avait l'obligation de le faire ça
pas été fait donc pour nous c'est de la
poudre aux yeux mais écoutez madame
sabine a quand même été la conseillère
monsieur rené lévesque lorsqu'il était
premier ministre à l'époque donc si
c'était bon pour monsieur les vagues ça
devrait être bon pour le bloc québécois
a le temps d'apprendre le français
depuis mais écoutez on va on va faire en
sorte justement de travailler avec elle
j'ai convaincu que lorsqu'elle va lire
le discours du trône d'un gouvernement
libéral à ce moment là elle va être en
mesure de le faire dans les deux langues
c'est ce que ça ouvre une porte par
contre est ce que vous pourriez faire
d'autres exceptions pour donner accès à
des autochtones ou à des membres
d'autres minorités des postes met de
côté les obligations du bilinguisme pour
faire de la place dans nos deux langues
sauf si elles sont très importantes et
la protection du français est au coeur
même de la nouvelle réforme sur les
langues officielles est en fait le parti
libéral on peut être fier de compter
dans nos rangs un caucus qui compte des
dominic leblanc démonique démons
affortit pardon des dents devant dale
des viviane la pointe des gens forts des
acadiens des franco ontariens et des
franco manitobains et grâce à ça on a
des voix forte contrairement au bloc
québécois qui se faire refuser une
rencontre par les acadiens qui peuvent
défendre leurs intérêts par eux-mêmes et
faire en sorte délire des voix fortes
libéral un peu partout à travers la
katiba suivi de maintenant vous savez
l'an dernier lors de la démission de
julie payette le conseil privé avait
émis un rapport sur la situation j'avais
demandé à consulter le rapport on m'a
répondu qu'il est disponible en anglais
seulement parce qu'il était à l'époque
disponible seulement dans la langue
d'origine où il avait été rédigé ce que
j'ai trouvé inacceptable
la plupart des fonctionnaires au conseil
privé sont des francophones qui doivent
parler anglais ou des anglophones la
voix francophone n'est pas entendue au
sommet de l'état et ça c'est un problème
qu'est ce qu'on doit changer pour que ça
s'améliore on doit installer une réelle
asymétrie encore là entre le français
qui est minoritaire au canada et
l'anglais qui est majoritaire de sorte
qu'on puisse donner accès réellement là
à des fonctionnaires qui ne seront pas
obligés de parler franglais où se
sentiront pas obligé de parler anglais
pour moi pour l'instant le gouvernement
fédéral à la tête cet anglophone mais
non mais écoutez c'est pas compliqué le
bloc québécois jeu ça supporter notre
projet de loi sur les langues sauf si on
va pouvoir changer
je lis de la place maintenant aux trois
autres candidats c'est à dire monsieur
rayess le sujet déclare monsieur chaque
est poursuivant sur le bilinguisme
selon-vous bilinguisme obligatoire est
ce que ça doit être un critère pour les
juges pour les autres postes de
direction les autres postes d'autorité
nommé par par le fédéral nous a passé
quoi monsieur chat kabyle tout à fait
assez et c'est ça qui est dommage de la
part des conservateurs c'est qu'il
n'accepte pas que ça c'est la dernière
instance judiciaire au pays la cour
suprême et que les citoyens francophones
qui vont devoir les battre lavaur
n'auront peut-être pas la chance d'avoir
les les juges des jeux devront
comprendre quand ils vont s'exprimer en
français et j'aimerais pas mentionné
quelque chose par rapport au programme
libéral qui est pas parfait non plus sur
la nomination des juges à la cour
suprême parce que ce que fait le
gouvernement libéral ce qu'il dit vous
avez le droit d'être entendu en français
devant les juges de la cour suprême
devant la cour suprême pardon mais
peut-être que si on y avait des gens qui
comme un gouvernement conservateur qui
ne m'aide et je jubile un unilingue
anglais mais peut-être que les gens
seraient obligés d'être devant cinq
juges sept juges au lieu d'avoir les
neufs juges devant un donc ça serait pas
une égalité réelle à ses romans chacun
d'entre eux ryan et merci ça me permette
de cléry fils point man je pense
monsieur choquette possibilité dernier
les airs des élections de bons chiffres
sur le sujet c'est clair que l'objectif
c'est d'avoir des juges qui sont
bilingues
malheureusement malheureusement ce
n'était pas le cas ils devront s'engager
la même chose que le garnement libéral
le fait pour la gouverneure générale
donc tu es c'est bizarre d'entendre
madame madame joly nous dit que pour la
gouverneure générale on peut accepter
qu'il ne parle pas les deux langues
officielles la représentante du pays et
qu'on va accepter simplement qu'elle
s'engage à apprendre le français mais
que pour les jeux je sais pas
nécessairement la même situation donc
notre objectif est clair il faudrait que
les juges lorsqu'ils sont nommés par les
deux langues officielles ici pour une
question de compétence une des pôles qu
il devrait s'engager de montrer leur
bonne foi pour l'apprendre ce que vous
diront si je pense que l'objectif de la
compétence est une priorité le français
une priorité et sliimy nice avait été
sérieuse l heure déposer son projet de
loi sur les deux langues officielles la
modernisation à vendre qu'on tombe en
élection donc pas d'obligation de
mais c'est clair qu'il faut en faire la
promotion c'est clair qu'il faut
chercher dans l'ensemble du pays on a la
capacité de nommer des juges bilingues
mais en même temps il faut s'assurer que
si pour différentes raisons on avait la
meilleure personne à dans une province
et qu'elle ne maîtrisait pas totalement
le français devrait s'engager
formellement au même titre que la
gouverneure générale on lui a demandé à
nicolas sur le bilinguisme obligatoire
c'est sûr que le français c'est une
langue complexe le demander à quelqu'un
de l'apprendre une fois rendu en poste
me semble pas évident ça manque
quelqu'un qui est vraiment une grande
volonté une certaine facilité avec
l'élan et moi un problème que je
constate beaucoup dans la fonction
publique fédérale c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup d'anglophones qui ont des
primes parce qu'ils parlent soit disant
que français sauf que il ne le parle
jamais dans le milieu de travail il ne
le parle jamais avec leurs employés
francophones donc faut pas juste que ça
soit une exigence du poste faut que ça
soit vérifiée faut que la personne
n'utilise le français antoine koch puis
après ça s'est fini pitt en prime non
faut aller plus loin je pense qu'il y
avait un bon projet de loi
malheureusement on a une élection tout
le monde s'entend tout cas pour bonifier
le bilinguisme c'est la bonne nouvelle
on passe maintenant au deuxième thème de
ce débat
[Musique]
alors on va parler éducation cours des
prochaines minutes on va se déplacer à
toronto la question nous vient de la
chef d'antenne du téléjournal ontario
gabriel sabourin les récents déboires
financiers de l'université laurentienne
de sudbury ont mis en lumière les défis
voir les difficultés de plusieurs
établissements post secondaires de
langue française au pays on n'a qu'à
penser au campus saint-jean de
l'université de l'alberta ou encore à
l'université de moncton tous les deux
dans une situation financière précaire
quelles actions concrètes
allez vous prendre pour assurer que les
francophones de partout au pays est
accès à une éducation post secondaire en
français pour ainsi assurer la pérennité
et la vitalité de toutes les communautés
francophones du pays
une très bonne question je conte
publireportage qu'on a fait sur cet
enjeu d'éducation français un peu
partout pays dans les derniers mois
débat ouvert avec vous 5 mai civile mais
vous avez le premier droit de parole
l'éducation français est un droit le
gouvernement libéral n'a pas agi durant
six ans les universités
franck ontarienne acadienne ont
contribué on continuer à perdre de
l'importance à perte du financement et
si je prends la situation québec des
institutions comme le collège dawson
comme l'université mcgill reçoivent un
financement disproportionné par rapport
à l'importance de la minorité le bloc
québécois propose que soit instauré une
réelle politique pour faciliter le
français n'ont pas assuré le bilinguisme
institutionnel encore le jeu toute
proposition est en fait la position du
parti libéral c'est clair qu'il faut
appuyer le continuum en éducation la
meilleure façon qu'un enfant plus vivant
français c'est qu'ils puissent avoir
accès une garderie en france est
rapidement donc nous on est en faveur
d'un système universel de garderie ce
que les conservateurs veulent scrappé
est premièrement deuxièmement on est en
faveur aussi du fait que cet enfant
l'homme puisse continuer au primaire au
secondaire et éventuellement au
postsecondaire en français et on a été
là pour défendre les franco-ontariens
contre le gouvernement conservateur de
john ford pour établir une première
université pas répond des francophones
en ontario on a signé cette entente avec
le gouvernement ford est également on
est là en doublant le budget pour nos
universités et collèges partout à
travers le pays qui sont en situation
minoritaire et en assurant leur
pérennité et donc pour le campus 1 re à
l'université de moncton également à
l'université
je vous dis le jeu le poil qui brûle les
lèvres quand j'écoute les ministres
parler ça fait six ans que sont au
pouvoir la seule chose que les milices
est capable de dire c'est de critiquer
les premiers ministres provinciaux parce
qu'ils ne viennent pas de la même
affiliation politique qu'elle ça fait
partie de notre constitution de déforme
les communautés en situation minoritaire
ça fait six ans qui manque de
financement on s'est engagé de notre
côté clairement c'est écrire dans la
plateforme de mettre en place un fonds
de 30 millions par année pour soutenir
le financement des universités partout
sur l'ensemble du territoire qui sont en
situation minoritaire puis on a vu les
pronostics ont été très bien nommé dans
la question deuxièmement c'est important
aussi de soutenir nos écoles primaires
et secondaires parce que faut pas juste
parler des programmes qui sont en
immersion comme laminé ce pas il faut
parler des écoles francophones y les
gens ont besoin d'avoir du soutien
financier pour les élèves mais aussi
pour le personnel que l'on forme dans
les universités que vont faire les
comptes inutile si par la suite monsieur
reyes reçu j'adore oui ce qu'il faut
dire par contre c'est que et que ce que
ce soit le parti libéral que ce soit les
partis conservateurs c'est extrêmement
important comme il comme le lisent
d'abord un continuum dans l'éducation de
la petite enfance jusqu'aux postes
secondaires le problème c ur vont-ils
prendre l'argent les conservateurs avec
la façon qui ne qui nous mais nous amène
vers l'austérité encore une fois les
libéraux y oublie d'aller chercher les
richesses nous ce qu'on a dit c'est
qu'on va mettre un impôt sur les grandes
fortunes des 10 millions et plus on va
les augmenter les impôts des grandes
entreprises ont beau faire payer les
impôts des gaffes à des géants du web
qui font pas leur juste part
présentement est comme ça oui on va
pouvoir investir dans nos communautés de
langue officielle en situation normale
dans nos francophones parce que si on ne
fait pas ça c'est pas vrai que l'argent
va tomber du ciel qu'on va être capable
de s'investir pour nos communautés
changer après l'université tout alors
qu'est-ce que vous probablement c'est
pas avec toi mignon qu'on va aller très
loin oui c'est des gouvernements
conservateurs qui ont coupé dans
l'éducation post secondaire en français
donc s'associer réalité donc à partir de
là ça prend un financement stable pour
ces institutions là avec des ententes
avec les provinces et des exigences
solide parce que il ya un changement de
gouvernement il ya un changement de
financement c'est toujours à recommencer
les une version besoin d'un financement
stable qui s'étale sur plusieurs années
c'est comme ça que mon pouvoir se
développer créer des nouveaux programmes
pour répondre aux besoins de notre
économie qui est en train de se
transformer par une économie plus verte
en fait c'est ce qu'on devrait ce que
c'est suffisant ce que vous proposez
comme investissement j'entendais la
politologue geneviève galy ce matin qui
disait le budget de l'université
d'ottawa c'est un milliard et l'on parle
de quelques dizaines de millions ça
prend plus que
l'annoncé juste en fait cet été 100 avec
un million pour nos universités collèges
jean sasson minoritaires et en plus dans
notre plateforme on dit qu'on veut
doubler le budget normalement du
gouvernement
ont fait en sorte de mettre 80 millions
par année et de façon permanente
rapidement mais serait si vous ou votre
30 millions
le 30 millions directement pour les
écoles universitaires post secondaire
partout payer pour les soutenir
minimalement et un fort pour soutenir
les écoles primaires secondaires scène
avec un outil francophones toujours sur
le thème de l'éducation face à face
maintenant être allé reyes et franche
strasse où chaque est on va parler des
garderies on l'a abordé brièvement il
est des francophones partout pays qui
dénonce le manque de places dans les
garderies plusieurs se tourner vers des
garderies anglophones ou abandonnent
leur emploi pour rester à la maison
s'occuper de leurs enfants c'est quoi
votre plan pour augmenter le nombre de
places de garderie en langue française
est ce qu'on doit attacher du sud les
transferts à des places francophone est
ce qu'on doit garantir une proportion
francophone pour les transferts fédéraux
tout à fait si on prend le continuum
comme on parlait tout à l'heure l'autre
dans l'indication pour commencer avec la
petite enfance si nos jeunes
francophones ne vont pas la petite
enfance qu est ce qui arrive on la
petite enfance en anglais ils vont super
anglicisé malheureusement ils vont
passer plus de temps la petite halle à
l'aide à la garderie qu'à la maison et
quand ils reviennent à l'école
francophone il faut lire francisée et
loïc est ce qui va arriver l'insécurité
linguistique qu'est ce qui arriva le
cadre de l' insécurité linguistique
malheureusement on en oublie yong-ho
futur notre propre vocabulaire puis
parfois on arrête de parler notre langue
on y ressemble moins à l'aise de parler
la langue française donc la petite
enfance c'est essentiel pour la survie
de nos francophones partout au pays il
faut absolument investir là dedans et
nous on avait déjà mentionné depuis 2015
2015 qu'on voulait investir un programme
pancanadien
de la petite enfance avec des clauses
linguistique ça prend des clauses
linguistique et madame joly
malheureusement dans ce dans les
ententes qui se passe présentement je
sais quand je te jeter bas avec monsieur
reyes a juste mentionné
il n'y a pas de clause linguistique
présentement c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut ajouter parce qu'au titre des
hypocrites au conservatoire ils veulent
comme le m disc gauche parce que vous
êtes pareils comme madame joly pas c'est
vrai ils veulent scrappé le dos tres la
garder
pour tout le monde donc on veut aider
les familles directement on veut donner
crédit dépôt pour chaque famille qu'un
enfant et qui cherche du financement
pour pour se trouver une place dans une
garderie est une compétence sain
souligné provincial donc il faut aussi
respecter les juridictions provinciales
du côté du côté du québec tandis que
déjà un système en place de services de
garde on s'est engagé à s'asseoir avec
le premier ministre françois legault
pour s'assurer de respecter les sommes
d'argent qu'il y avait
qui ne s'attend à recevoir de son côté
mais de l'autre côté il faut être
capable dans chacune des nouvelles
mesures qui sont mises en place de
s'assurer que la place du français soit
bien nommé puis pour ça ça va prendre du
leadership politique est présentement
c'est pour ce que l'on a vu dans la
dernière année plus de recueillir de
surtout parce que man dans les deux
dernières années comme le démontre et le
commissaire ou deux langues officielles
mais aussi je pense que c'est le temps
qui est un changement merci messieurs
reyes les trois autres candidats
maintenant confrontation sur le thème
des garderies toujours rené villemure
mélanie joly luc jolicoeur est ce qu'il
doit y avoir aujourd'hui un seul
conditions linguistiques des transferts
de tahoua pour garantir des places en
français mais sujet les quatre premiers
de ses claques le blog vous devons nous
dire non mais attends de garderie ça
prend un programme universel puis dans
le programme universel voir des
discussions avec les provinces puis
vendée certains apparemment nationaux
pas une abondance mais un détail puis
d'aider à faire il pas détaillé comme le
npd veut mais ça ça va prendre ça va
prendre les paramètres qu'il faut qu'ils
aient un financement stable à partir de
la petite enfance juste jusqu'aux
universités et pour les garderies c'est
un programme national l'idée des
conservateurs ça ne fonctionne pas pensé
il avait le choix en lâcher votre job
pour conserver votre langue celle de
votre filiation de vos enfants ou
envoyer votre vos enfant dans une
garderie anglophones c'est inacceptable
faut que le système change puis
rapidement comme un gars assez malade
jeudi dans votre plat des places pour
les francophones spécifiquement mais on
avait déjà signé dans un premier temps
des ententes avec les gouvernements
provinciaux et on avait prévu des
clauses linguistique pour des places en
garderie francophone mais là c'est la
première fois en fait qu'on a des
ententes signées avec plusieurs
provinces dont le gouvernement du québec
mais aussi la colombie tannique
plusieurs gouvernements en atlantique et
un montant de 32 milliards de dollars
pour faire en sorte qu'on a un système
universel de garderie qui veut faire en
sorte que 250 mille femmes qui vont
pouvoir rejoindre le marché du travail
et donc c'est bon pour l'économie mais
aussi c'est bon pour la protection du
français parce que je suis très que très
d'accord avec ce que mon collègue dit
c'est un défi en situation minoritaire
d'envoyer un enfant dans une garderie
francophone et pour contrer la
simulation c'est extrêmement important
que nos enfants puissent avoir accès à
des services de petite enfance dès leur
plus jeune âge dans la langue la
minorité donc en français merci
messieurs ville mais assurément
l'éducation d'une compétence provinciale
compétences du québec dans ce que 6 et
que l'on désire préserver le transfert
doit être fait pour le québec sans
condition pour le reste du canada il est
triste de voir que parfois un grand
parent ne peut pas parler la même langue
de son petit enfant parce que tous les
deux ans entre les deux le français
s'est perdu et que le jeune est
malheureusement obligés de prendre
l'anglais je pense qu'un modèle qui peut
être pris au québec sur ce qui a été
fait et on peut le transposer dans les
autres provinces parce que pour nous le
succès est évident le modèle libéral a
été calqué sur le modèle du québec qui
est un succès donc on insiste pour avoir
les transferts sans condition on va
assurer la drire la prédominance du
français
conformément à la chaire de langue
française mais la réalité c'est que le
bloc québécois sera pas capable de faire
en sorte de défendre les intérêts des
québécois même sur les places en
garderie c'est le gouvernement
conservateur est élu et que à ce moment
là on déchire on scrap on annule la
fameuse entente qu'on a signés nous avec
le gouvernement le go pour les 30000
places en garderie qui manque au québec
mais au-delà de ça aussi c'est paul bloc
québécois qui va pouvoir empêcher des
coupes en culture comme c'était le cas
sous le gouvernement harper des coupes
aussi à radio-canada et des coupes dans
les services en français au sein du
gouvernement fédéral attention monsieur
grübel franchement c'est ahurissant et
claires et c'est vrai les certaines coop
ont eu lieu sous les covenants précédent
mais parlons de votre gouvernement ou un
pack plusieurs instances n'ont pas été
financé on était sous financée encore là
vous assurez le bilinguisme vous
permettez aux institutions anglophones
d'enseignement de prendre une place sur
dimensionné merci monsieur villemur a
déjà ça passe vite a déjà notre
troisième thème dont vous le présente à
l'instant
on va maintenant aborder les défis au
plan de l'économie parler entre autres
de la fameuse pénurie de main d'oeuvre
dont on entend parler et on se dirige en
acadie pour la question de la chef
d'antenne du téléjournal acadie
marie-hélène lange
bonsoir la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
frappe de plein fouet plusieurs régions
au pays les conséquences se font
d'ailleurs de plus en plus sentir au
nouveau brunswick par exemple un
district scolaire n'arrivent pas à
trouver de conducteurs d'autobus qui
parlent français des trajets doivent
donc être annulé des hôpitaux manquent
de personnel on a vu des départements de
soins intensifs d'obstétrique fermé cet
été un regroupement de gens d'affaires
souhaite que le nouveau brunswick
accueille dix mille migrants d'ici 2024
dont le tiers seraient francophone alors
ma question ce soir que compte faire
votre parti pour attirer des immigrants
francophones
notre bonne question débat ouvert avec
les cinq candidats monsieur rayess le
premier à parler merci la question était
fait pertinente il ya un grave problème
en ce moment au pays il faut s'attaquer
à l'immigration francophone depuis 2003
n'avons pas atteint les cibles qui ont
été mis en place par le gouvernement
c'est une grave lacune il faut changer
notre approche par rapport à ça un
deuxième problème que nous avons on
signe des ententes internationales
mais même à l'intérieur de nos provinces
on a une problématique à arrimer la
reconnaissance des compétences donc on
pourra voir dans certains cas des gens
qui seraient prêts à les aider dans une
province qui maîtrisent la langue du
français mais qui sont pris à cause des
règles étant donné que les différends
ord qui représentent les différentes
professions sont différentes d'une
province à l'autre et pour ça ça va
prendre un leadership au niveau du
gouvernement pour aider dans cette
courte dans cette coordination afin que
l'on y arrive et dernière chose c'est à
dire il va avoir un plan de relance post
pandémique est important que dans ce
plan de relance d'une lentille
francophones qui souhaitent utiliser
afin de s'assurer que dans chacune des
mesures qui seront mis en place on
puisse tenir compte du français merci
monsieur khallas comme augmenter
l'immigration francophone mais c'est sûr
que l'immigration francophone c'est une
priorité d'ailleurs pour la première
fois dans le dernier plan d'action sur
les langues officielles on en a fait une
priorité on a mis un budget mais là il
faut aller encore plus loin parce que la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre elle est réelle
du québec en a 40 en acadie partout à
travers le pays et pour ce pur pour
gérer cet enjeu leur faut faire deux
choses augmenter l'immigration de façon
générale et s'assurer qu'on en ait une
stratégie l'immigration francophone
d'ailleurs dans notre projet de loi sur
les langues officielles on en fait une
obligation pour le gouvernement de le
faire contrairement aux conservateurs
est également on doit absolument avoir
un système national de garderie parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on va pouvoir
faire en sorte que des femmes puissent
aussi joindre le marché du travail
finalement dernier point ya une pénurie
d'enseignants au pays et donc nous on a
dit qu'on allait faire en sorte
d'attirer les meilleurs talents meilleur
prof de français dans le monde si
physiquement c'est notre prochaine sous
question va pas les installer devant
celle à la parade monsieur villemur sur
les immigrants comment on fait pour
attirer davantage première chose la
pénurie mais doivent exister avant la
pandémie mais cependant la pandémie a
été a aggravé la pénurie avec la paix si
la pcr appelez le comme vous voulez mais
néanmoins on a quand même tué une partie
de la main d'oeuvre là dessus
présentement il manque des gens sur
l'immigration le bloc québécois insiste
pourra obtenir un transfert sans
condition du programme d immigration
d'immigrants francophones on sait mieux
que quiconque qu'est ce que ça prend
afin d'être bien intégré de bien
fonctionner et on ne peut pas laisser à
un autre palier de gouvernement le désir
ou de mettre certaines conditions qui ne
s'applique pas les tests de français
pour certains immigrants sont faits à
partir de tests de français aient émis
en france lestrade or sont pas les mêmes
ça pas de sens certaines permettez moi
d'ajouter que par rapport à justement
l'immigration je pense que les
conservateurs et les libéraux ont manqué
leur cible à plusieurs reprises donc
assez peut-être 4% maintenance et de 4
points 4 % et ce type de ne jamais été
atteinte avant même qu'on parle de
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre faudrait parler
de poids démographique de nos
francophone le poids démographique de
nos francophone dix minutes 10 minutes
10 minutes tout le temps et quand on
parle d'immigration la série étaient ses
projets oui on va essayer de le faire il
faut vraiment atteindre cela il faudra
avoir oui la lentille francophones mais
où aussi un investissement dans les
églises les lions pardon dans le post
secondaire il faudrait avoir des
missions par exemple en europe en
afrique du nord pour aller chercher des
francophones faudra voir un bassin
francophone d'immigration ses urgences
on peut pas tout se permettre de
continuer à descendre notre poids
démographique de chaque être le sujet
délicat je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui vient des dix paroles le npd
par monsieur fréchette là il ya un
problème il n'y a pas assez
d'immigration francophone la
reconnaissance des diplômes et des
compétences des gens qui viennent
s'installer au canada c'est beaucoup
trop long le système de gestion de
l'immigration at large l'oeuf avec des
délais de trois ans le sait ça
fonctionne pas du tout faut régler ça au
plus vite et il faut avoir plus on parle
des migrants francophones on parle de
quelque chose d'important l'europe alde
chauffeur d'ambulance des gens qui sont
pas capables d'avoir des services de
santé en français
merci on parle aussi d'enseignants et
d'enseignantes on y arrive justement
face à face madame joly monsieur j'ai
dit qu'à la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre je
parlais du milieu de l'enseignement mais
le milieu de la santé aussi c'est
extrêmement criaient ya des passeurs
francophones qui n'arrive pas à se faire
soigner dans leur langue on peut
imaginer la barrière linguistique on est
devant un médecin anglophone il y aussi
des d'aider des parents qui réussissent
pas à inscrire leurs enfants à l'école
offre à c'est pas ce qui manque
d'enseignants concrètement vous faites
quoi pour attirer et retenir du
personnel en santé et en éducation le
sujet licka
d'abord il faut les faire venir il faut
aussi que les gens passent à travers le
système d'éducation donc faut améliorer
le système d'éducation pour améliorer le
système d'immigration et pour retenir
les gens en emploi
ça c'est sûr que si c'est des questions
de santé ou d'éducation
il ya un volet que c'est une compétence
provinciale mais l'autre volet c'est que
ça prend un financement stable comme
j'en ai parlé tantôt en éducation la
même chose en santé pour que les
gouvernements provincial
de ouvrir fermer les robinets à tout
bout de champ donc ça prend de la
stabilité dans les programmes de
transferts fédéraux il faut mettre fin à
des réduction des financements des
provinces en santé et en éducation qui
ont débuté sur fond de foudre souligné
il va de soi que je suis d'accord avec
mon collègue npd c'est très important
qu'on maintienne le poids des
francophones au sein de la fédération et
donc pour y arriver étant donné qu'on
est un pays qui a grandement bénéficié
de l'immigration c'est important qu'on a
une stratégie d'éducation francophone
tels que je les mentionnaient tantôt
qu'on en fasse une obligation pour que
notre prochain gouvernement mais aussi
tous les gouvernements à venir soient
obligés d'attirer vraiment un bassin
important d'immigrants francophones et
là dedans on veut les meilleurs talents
on fait en mesure d'avoir les bons
enseignants donc attirer les meilleurs
propres à travers le monde d'ailleurs on
crée un corridor des migrations pour les
enseignants on veut aussi reconnaître
leur diplôme travailler avec tous les
ministres de l'éducation à travers le
pays sur cette question d'ailleurs j'ai
eu plusieurs conversations avec eux ils
étaient tous d'accord et finalement
dernier point il va de soi que
présentement on est dans une crise
sanitaire qui crée une crise économique
c'est très important qu'on ait le
personnel soignant nécessaires pour
aider les personnes qui en ont besoin et
qui ont recours au système de santé et
c'est important qu'ils puissent le faire
aussi dans leur langue parce que on sait
lorsqu'on est malade on est vulnérable
et on a besoin d'être capable de parler
sa langue de parler le français est donc
dans les circonstances qu'on va faire si
on va augmenter les transferts de santé
en santé aux provinces 25 millions 1,25
milliard pardon par année et on veut
faire en sorte de recruter 7500
personnes elles mêmes je lis des bas à 3
m monsieur reyes monsieur choquette
monsieur villemur toujours sur la
question de la pénurie mais d'offres
quel est votre plan pour attirer et
retenir des travailleurs oublions le
plessis de compte un peu l'immigration
le mic pour se concentrer là dessus
maintenant vous fait quoi
comment oui ali daffé merci vraiment il
faut travailler sur la question tantôt
gelé mentionné la question des
reconnaissance des acquis et on doit
être capable de travailler même à
l'intérieur de notre propre
confédération pour enlever de la
bureaucratie présentement le jeu que
dans ma circonscription une entreprise
une clinique de physiothérapie crise a
tiré une physiothérapeute de suisse qui
parle parfaitement le français ça fait
six mois qu'elle est en attente de
l'autorisation de son visa parce que les
fonctionnaires gouvernement fédéral lui
dise que ça prend une autorisation de
son normes et de ce côté son ordre leur
dis lui dit ben ça vous prend votre
bizarre si vous voulez que je vous donne
l'autorisation de l'or pour pouvoir
pratiquer on parle de plusieurs mois
d'attentes présentement pour un coût
extrêmement simple qui devrait être
réglé rapidement donc on doit s'attaquer
à ce pour ça ça va prendre du leadership
s'apprendre du partenariat anti province
pour faire en sorte que la médiocre puis
7 mobile pour que lorsque des besoins
d'endroit plus les majeures en plus de
l'éducation post secondaire dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure qu'il faut
absolument soutenir et puis le
continuant bien sûr en éducation faut
pas oublier non plus que il ya des
personnes anglophones qui veulent
apprendre le français qui vont même
campé littéralement devant les écoles
d'immersion française et pourra pour
aller s'inscrire parce que pas de place
ils vont camper des fois des jours de la
nuit même pour avoir de la place chance
d'apprendre le français alors ça ça peut
aider aussi à notre pénurie de main
d'oeuvre de franciser plus d'anglophones
et comme yoda d'oman mais il faut juste
faire plus d'offres et cela je pense que
le gouvernement actuel ne pas ne pas
faire assez dans ce domaine là pour la
francisation
pour permettre justement aux anglophones
qui veulent apprendre le français
d'avoir plus de place dans les écoles
d'immersion française
merci suivi le sera l'attraction la
réparation des travailleurs il est
certain que les ordres professionnels
qui sont des créatures provincial quand
même sous le feu des provisions québec
eux ont des délais qui sont honnêtement
assez long et c'est complexe immigré au
québec si complexe immigré au canada
donc je comprends qu'on en fasse une
bonne promotion mais les délais josette
eu beaucoup d'initiatives maintenant
c'est un champ de compétence des
provinces le fédéral ne peut pas
intervenir comme ça avec des grosses
bottines sans rien dire mais il reste
que la sélection
l'offre d'un milieu de vie en français
va rassurer les gens savoir qu'ils vont
pouvoir être acceptée fonctionner parmi
les autres et puis pour voir faire la
queue leurs enfants n'auront pas être en
insécurité passe enfin par rapport à la
linguistique donc c'est certain que les
délais par rapport à l'immigration en
termes professionnels mais les délais
simplement gouvernementaux sont
inacceptables mais vous pouvez pas
vraiment aux attaques à ce que vous
l'avez dit les approvisionnements sont
des créatures des provinces et puis
chaque province une gestion un peu
différente malheureusement plusieurs
essais ont été faits puis encore la
formule magique est encore à trouver
merci beaucoup déjà arrivé à notre
quatrième thème on va parler culture
[Musique]
alors déjà le dernier à grands thèmes de
ce débat sur les enjeux francophone on
va consacrer les prochaines minutes à
parler de culture la question de vielles
de la région de l'estrie voici chantal
reeves et qui anime le téléjournal
estrie
bonsoir statistique canada rapporte
qu'en 2020 un travailleur sur quatre du
milieu culturel a perdu son emploi ici
en extrait des graphistes des auteurs
compositeurs interprètes les producteurs
réalisateurs concepteur d'éclairages
entre autres réclament d'une seule voix
un rattrapage économique pour les arts
et la culture il constate aussi depuis
20 ans l'exode des talents vers les
grands centres urbains comment comptez
vous soutenir les arts dans la
francophonie canadienne tant au niveau
du financement que de la rétention de la
relève en région
alors soutien aux arts aux artistes un
peu partout pays débats 5 mai sujet du
caire d'abba d'abord le gros problème
avec les mesures qui ont été mis en
place pour la pandémie c'est qu'il faut
lui les mettre en place si on avait un
revenu minimum garanti
automatiquement tout le monde qui a
besoin d'être auraient été couverts et
ya plusieurs artistes qui n'ont jamais
reçu leurs chèques ou qu'ils ont reçus
après qu'on ait modifié les programmes
sociaux la première chose la deuxième
chose nous on veut augmenter d'un
milliard sur trois ans le financement
aux grandes institutions culturelles
canadien de c'est essentiel ils sont
sous financés dans le moment et on veut
aussi aider le développement de contenu
autochtone et francophones pour les
plateformes numériques on pense qu'il
devra des exigences de contenu canadien
sur les plateformes les grandes
plateformes numériques parce que c'est
plate forme là sont de plus en plus
impopulaire et on n'a pas assez de
contenu canadien donc si on aura
l'occasion des revenus ce qui d'autre
voter revient en fait vous savez les
artistes oui en effet tout le secteur
des arts de la culture des ans des
industries créatives ont été très
affectés par la pandémie est pour ça qu
on a répondu présent en offrant un filet
social à toutes les personnes qui ont
perdu leur emploi mais aussi en faisant
en sorte que le conseil des arts que
téléfilm canada que l'eau nf toutes nos
institutions culturelles
mettent l'épaule à la roue pour faire en
sorte justement qu'on passe à travers
cette crise là et on pense aussi qu'on
doit continuer d'aider le secteur parce
que dans le fond au cours des prochains
mois cette pandémie va quand même
continuer on sait que le secteur va être
encore affectés donc la subvention
salariale et l'aide au loyer doit
continuer pour le secteur des arts et de
la culture libérale je serais d'accord
madame joly que le célèbrerons salariale
doit continuer pour secteur des arts et
des artistes d'ailleurs intéressant de
songer à installer un filet social pour
les artistes qui d'années après année de
cette manière pandémie ou non souffre
néanmoins non pas de conditions de
travail qui sont acceptables les arts
c'est un peu la culture c'est l'identité
sait qui on est ainsi au delà du
divertissement mais néanmoins taxer les
gars femmes mais de manière
substantielle pas seulement symbolique
et puis s'assurer que justement on
puisse réinvestir en culture le bloc
proposé mais ces 300 millions à culture
sur le prochain mandat afin d'aider le
soutien aux arts en général mais il
reste que la taxation là les nouveaux
moyens de diffusion sont pas adaptés à
la réalité économique des artistes il
faut faire un petit effort de réflexion
là dessus nous proposons un filet social
pour les artistes mais nous on est en
faveur de la taxation des géants du web
est aussi on pense qu'on avait une loi
sur la radiodiffusion projet de loi qui
a été déposé moi je dois contre
lesquelles
on fait alors je vous arrête on y
arriver tout à l'heure dans les
prochaines minutes de
faire du pouce sur justement ce projet
de loi c-10 que les libéraux en
garrocher à la toute fin qui nous en en
élections ce projet de loi sur la
radiodiffusion la motivation de
radiodiffusion tous les partis
d'opposition ont dû se battre à
l'intérieur du comité pour faire une
place au français dans ce projet de loi
parce que aucune balise avait émis par
les libéraux afin de s'assurer que la
production française au juste la
programmation donc avec des sous titres
ou avec des traductions mais que de la
production française soit inclus dans le
projet de loi afin que nos artistes ici
au québec au canada en acadie dans
toutes les communautés francophones
puissent contribuer à cet essor culturel
en quand j'entends les ministres nous
parler de cette façon là je suis
vraiment extrêmement je suis un et deux
matches en plus jeunes c'est
chacun qui peut parler encore là je
voudrais juste qu'on revient sur
l'importance du cas on va moderniser la
loi sur les langues officielles
d'inclure le fait que la culture et la
langue ça va de pair la langue française
et la culture c'est ça qui va nous nous
fait vivre qui nous que nous faire
épanouir c'est ça qui fait le tissu
culturel fait le tissu social de nos
communautés et c'est extrêmement
important
on regarde des endroits comme le campus
saint jean par exemple qui justement un
mélange de culture d'éducation
même d'économie de l'immigration ce qui
fait la richesse de cet endroit l'eau et
oui il faut réinvestir dans nos temps
nos artistes dans notre culture et
s'assurer aussi de trouver un moyen que
nos artistes ayant un revenu plus stable
et qu'ils soient bien sûr adapté merci
face à face maintenant toujours sur la
question de la culture à l'airé être ni
villemur bien des gens dans le milieu
culturel espère qu'ils gèrent du web on
en parlait investissent à nouveau dans
la production locale une façon d'assurer
la protection la promotion de la culture
francophone comment allez vous encadrer
ces entreprises là qui sont pas soumises
en ce moment aux mêmes règles que les
diffuseurs traditionnels le projet le
fameux projet de loi c-10 ont pas été
adopté au sénat vous proposez quoi si
vous êtes élu mais premièrement on s'est
engagés dans notre plateforme électorale
de s'assurer de mettre en place des
balises afin que les géants du web les
gelées grands diffuseurs comme netflix
spotify et tous les autres que l'on
connaît
assure une fois juste une programmation
mais une production francophone à
l'intérieur de ce qu'ils voient par
l'ensemble de la population canadienne
c'est un minimum on représente les
francophones au pays près du quart de la
population
on devrait s'attendre à avoir
relativement à peu près le même
pourcentage de contenu francophone sur
les différentes plateformes les grands
joueurs sont d'accord il faut juste
s'assurer de mettre en place les bonnes
balises à l'intérieur ce malheureusement
ce n'était aucunement à l'intérieur du
court doit ses disques gouvernement
libéral a déposé puis je tiens à
souligner ça a été un partenariat de
tous les partis d'opposition tant les
[ __ ] le bloc et le parti conservateur
qui ont forcé la main au ministre steven
guilbeault pour changer les règles
malheureusement trop peu trop tard ils
ont envoyé en élections élections que
personne ne voulait qu'ils font en sorte
qu'on va être obligé de recommencer
précision là dessus monsieur relief vous
avez tué saisissent le bloc était pour
que quelques fois d'accord avec le
gouvernement libéral certains
aménagements devait être fait ils ont
été faits sur le plan la francophonie
nous étions satisfaits donc quand même
c'est pas ça compte pas pour du beurre
vous avez sous prétexte de liberté
d'expression pris en otage le projet de
loi et l'avait fait mourir au feuilleton
il était arrivé tard j'en conviens j'en
conviens mais néanmoins ce projet lac
pourrait toujours être bonifié
d'ailleurs on pourrait s'inspirer de
certaines lois qui ont été passées par
la communauté européenne je le plante la
taxation des géants du web qui ont été
innovateur je penses tu des choses qui
peuvent être le fait mais de de faire de
l'obstruction systématique dans un
projet qui avait été bonifiée
franchement excusé monsieur mur je pense
que vous avez postulé très beau ce
processus là les experts partout au pays
des professeurs d'université aux
exploits qui ont dit non non excusez moi
des experts des professeurs d'université
publie néanmoins vous considériez que
ces gens ne sont pas crédibles ils sont
même financé par le gouvernement fédéral
par patrimoine canada pour leurs
recherches sur la liberté d'expression
ils ont tous dénoncé sans exception ce
changement de cap ample et mutent
processus d'un retrait d'un article qui
s'attaquait au contenu puis aux gens qui
déposent les chaussures les médias
sociaux risée donc
c'est beaucoup 3 les trois autres
candidats maintenant là-dessus
poursuivant sur ce fameux projet de loi
c-10 pourquoi malade je lis ça faisait
des mois des années qu'on vous demande
est encore là ça a été déposée juste
avant les élections ça fait juste avant
les élections ça faisait plus d'un an
qu'on ne débatte est donc le plus
important en fait c'est qu'on avait
enfin un projet de loi pour moderniser
la loi sur la radiodiffusion sonore
c'est ce qui fait en sorte que lorsqu'on
va regarder l'internet on va pouvoir se
reconnaître parce qu'on voir des films
qu'on va pouvoir voir aussi entendre la
musique qui a en français qui
représentent notre culture mais la
réalité c'est que les conservateurs ont
fait preuve non seulement d'obstruction
mais ayant voté contre
parce que l'air libertarienne des
conservateurs a plus d' influence et a
plus d'intérêt dans le parti que la
protection des artistes et des artistes
québécois et francophones au pays et
donc ce qui est arrivé dans les
circonstances c'est que malheureusement
le projet de loi peau de plus passé mais
au final ce qu'aurait qu'on est en
élection on va pouvoir travailler
ensemble parce que nous on veut re
déposé le projet de loi dans les 100
premiers jours de notre gouvernement est
aussi on veut augmenter le financement
de la production de films de la
production de série horrifique merci
c'est le des géants du web qui
croyez-vous qu'ils peuvent vraiment
faire relayer de les y est pour faire
payer il a juste part des géants du web
comme netflix facebook et les autres
géants du web de ce monde est-ce que
c'est mélanie joly qui a fait l'entente
netflix ou y avait à peine 25 millions
qui étaient supposés et pour les
francophones qui même point était au
complet pour les francophones est-ce que
c'est des conservateurs qu'il ait même
pas mettre de taxes sur les géants du
web non c'est le npd que c'est très fort
depuis le début sur le fait que les
géants du web doivent non seulement
payer leur juste part mais en plus
doivent avoir un procédé qui va exiger
la diffusion de contenus francophones
partout de partout au pays et aussi la
production de contenus francophones
partout au pays
que j'ai menées depuis le début que je
vais continuer à mener je le mène même
jusqu'à en cours présentement et je ne
vais pas m'arrêter et c'est extrêmement
important
c'est vrai que vous êtes traîner la
patte dessus adam genou est parfait si
netflix si je les patchs et de respect
pour vous merci madame malheureusement
vous et typo à la chambre des communes
au cours des deux dernières années on a
laissé la parole à monsieur licka sur
les ligier de jouer comment garantir une
portion de contenu francophone il faut
les taxer sont
tous d'accord sauf les conservateurs
probablement
j'allais dire assurément et l'autre
chose qu'il faut faire pour faut avoir
des normes de contenu avec avec des
exigences claires donc c'est pas vrai
que c'est d'user des gentlemen agreement
puis qu'on va travailler avec
l'industrie leur folle le même système
qui s'applique à la radio et la
télévision qui s'applique aux géants du
web c'est comme ça qu'on va qu'on va y
arriver il faut que les parties
travaillent ensemble nous on va
travailler avec le bloc le bloc avait
beaucoup travaillé là-dessus on
travaille avec le npd puis on va
travailler tout le monde pour s'assurer
que les francophones aient accès à du
contenu francophone sur les plateformes
numériques
mais il ya une expression qui dit que
quand t'es pas capable d'aider au moins
une nuit pas mais le problème avec les
conservateurs c'est que justement ils
n'ont pas voulu nécessairement aidé dans
la lah lucem à la modernisation de la
loi la radio mais aussi le npd a fait en
sorte qu'on n'a pas pu mais adopter
cette loi là parce qu'on a très bien on
fait en sorte de faire de jolies le
temps file des baux tire à sa fin chacun
des candidats et candidates auront une
quarantaine de secondes pour s'adresser
à vous une dernière fois j'aimerais que
vous gardez en tête cette question là si
vous aviez une priorité un dossier
important pour les francophones sur
lequel voulait travailler demain matin
c'est lequel mes sujets l'écart d'abord
le le dossier le plus important c'est
les services en français parce que tout
est lié
si on n'a pas suffisamment de services
en français les francophones vont perdre
leur langue les nous les nouveaux
arrivants francophones
s'intégreront pas aux communautés
francophones existantes donc ça prend
davantage de services en français et
quand on parle de service c'est
l'éducation c'est la santé mais si c'est
aussi les services offerts par le
gouvernement fédéral mais aussi les
entreprises privées en
télécommunications dans le secteur
bancaire
merci merci monsieur jolie campe sur
rail est votre priorité pour les
francophones la priorité numéro un pour
l'ensemble des francophones partout au
pays les québécois les franco ontariens
frank o mensch ou bien les acadiens
c'est de mettre en place enfin ce projet
de loi sur les deux langues officielles
le parti libéral a eu six ans pour
réaliser ce défi là ils ont déposé sept
jours avant la fin de la session et ils
ont propulsé dans une élection que
personne ne voulait s'apprennent loi que
du poids une loi qui va permettre un
nouveau tribunal administratif qui va
prendre les plaintes qui va donner plus
de poids comme ça avec des amendes
pécuniaires potentiel qui vont instaurer
un processus pour que toutes les
communautés parfois ils puissent
contribuer avec le merci mr alias madame
joly
on est tous préoccupés par l'état du
français au pays je vous ai rencontré
d'un bout à l'autre de l'acadie au yukon
en passant par la colombie britannique
où le pape m'avait parlé de votre
passion pour la langue française mais
également votre anxiété par rapport à
son futur c'est pour ça qu'il faut
déposer un nouveau projet de loi selon
un officiel comme on le fait dans le
dernier parlement et on vous doit faire
en sorte que tous les partis à
l'unission on soit en mesure de lancer
un message fort aux canadiens
canadiennes comme quoi les langues
officielles sont importantes et que la
protection du français est au coeur de
cette nouvelle vision et on peut le
faire aussi en protégeant les droits de
toutes les minorités linguistiques et en
augmente aussi le financement des
organismes madame joly monsieur chacun
de votre priorité pour les francophones
oui bien sûr et moderniser la loi sur
les langues officielles on est tous
d'accord c'est ce que les communautés de
langue officielle en situation
minoritaire demande si je dois choisir
une parce que il ya plusieurs priorités
et je pense qu'on doit pas négliger
aucune mais le continuum en éducation en
ce qui me concerne je pense que c'est
essentiel ça peut permettre à la survie
à l'épanouissement de nos communautés la
petite enfance on doit absolument
investir la petite enfance avoir des
places avoir des des éducatrices de
qualité qui vont offrir cette
possibilité lors de pays en france et le
shaq est monsieur gilbert il faut enfin
reconnaître que le français est une
langue minoritaire au pays et quand on
parle deux langues officielles ne sont
pas sur le même pied d'égalité il ya une
asymétrie faut reconnaître la symétrie
il faut donner l'exemple au gouvernement
fédéral en cessant de faire des
nominations de personnes anglophones qui
promettent de pâtes d'apprendre à parler
français il faut reconnaître que le
bilinguisme institutionnel ne fonctionne
pas il faut cesser de donner le droit
aux anglophones de travailler en anglais
dans les entreprises fédérales on doit
donc donner l'exemple aller de l'avant
et faire plus 6 ans étaient longs sans
rien faire et maintenant il faut à
quelque part agir de manière ferme merci
beaucoup monsieur villemur c'est ce qui
conclut déjà ce débat sur les enjeux
francophone merci aux candidats et
candidates d'y avoir participé je vous
souhaite une bonne fin de campagne on
est vraiment dans le dernier droit merci
à vous à la maison nous avons suivi on
espère qu'elle exercice vous aurait été
utile merci à l'équipe technique en
régie ici au centre national des arts et
si mathieu nadeau bonnes fêtes soirée à
très bientôt
[Musique]
à